is people locally from
france
so he's talking about sample me from
what's inside very famous
thank you and
thank you for the invitation and for
this uh workshop i've learned a lot
it's been interesting so thank you for
the to the organizers
and um
i hope
i'm going to interest some people in
this problem here so it's a
problem i've been working on for like
maybe a year but um we are kind of stuck
so i've been working with uh sherb
shield
magaly tony and jack leonard
marseille
so sharing uh what we've done so far i
hope that it will catch your interest
and
we can go off like we can move and find
something
um
like from find more results on this
problem
the problem that i'm interested in is
something from the vasathtime by center
so i'm going to start by defining the
barycenter so by center is a notion of
average
so i'm just going to um look at the
definition of averaging oops
yeah
and uh rd and and try to
see how to extend it so when i have a
bunch of points on
rd that are my x i i want to find a
point in the middle like that sum up all
my uh my data and for that
we use
the average that happens to be also
the admin
of
uh the variance
uh what we call the variance of my data
which uh uh it i mean in x
and seeing this definition i'm allowed
to
have a definition of my uh
averaging
depending only on my distance so this is
a clear norm
and
allowing this point of view from this
point of view i'm allowed
to uh
define
the same thing on the sphere so on the
sphere i am i have a geodesic space as
far as the judicial space when i
i look at the angular metric on it
and
um when i have points
i need my x size here
if i denote by uh so s is my sphere and
this uh its metric then i'm allowed to
define uh
the
whatever we call x bar my average
as the minimum
of the distance between x i
and x squared
again this is uh what is called the
pressure mean or the barycenter of my
points that allow to def that
allows me to define
uh
averaging in two digit spaces or metric
spaces
okay so
the space that i'm interested in the
vasa time space i'm just going to
quickly
remind the versatile distance even if
everybody know what it is what it is
here just to set up the notation
so i have two measures mu0 and u1 in my
versatile space my space of measures
with second order moment and i'm looking
at the infamous old couplings that i
will denote
gamma of mu01 all the couplings between
mu00 and u1
and i will uh do not buy a little gamma
or such couplings
and it has
three
properties that i will use
this versatile space the geodesic space
just like the sphere that i mentioned
before
it is positively curved just like the
spheres i mentioned before and i will
use this fear as a
like a stereotype of my social space to
make some drawings
and when mu zero is uh absolutely
continuous with respect to the bags and
my gamma star that is the optimum here
i
has this
brand new map
okay that i denote t from zero to mu 1.
now
from that i have my
geodesic space and my matrix space on
which i can define my barycenters i have
my measures mu 1 to mu 0 there are
priority measures i can associate
weights that have a slightly more
general definition of
price center
and i can look at mu star a different
star as an argument
of my average distance that i will
write here f of mu
is a function of mu and i will look at
for the mu the measurements that
is was centered in my data
so minimize this variance of
two
things here the barry center always
exists this
was proved in the paper of again carlier
who introduced
the barycenter and version 10 space
but it's however not always unique and
that will be one of the
issues we have
that we have and try to deal with
and so the question we're interested in
here is how to compute this new star
from the miui that i have
so the different settings in which we
can look at this problem uh the one that
is probably the most commonly studied is
the one was the new eyes the measures
from utah and tech my various centers
are direct masses are like a sum of jerk
masses or finally supported measures
and from that i have my n measures
supported on
big n
points
and then my coupling will be a tensor
and we've seen some talks about it
earlier i can use a different kind of
algorithm including a synchron algorithm
to reduce this tensor
to something uh
with a less dimension
but this has been proven to be a np
heart compute the bias center or to
approximate this variance has been
proven to be np hard when you look at
the
number of points the numbers of
marginals in the dimension
by json and x that was they were here
earlier this semester and so we're gonna
try to take a another setting
where instead we suppose that our the
exercises that are above are actually
drawn from something procedure like if
we suppose i have drawn from a sampling
procedure we have more knowledge like we
have this actual sampling procedure we
can create our own sampling procedure so
suppose that we have instead access
to let's say the ground log of miui
for each of the new eyes
now how can we sample directly from new
star having this noise so one typical
thing would be but i first
sampled my new eyes and then i do what
is already done but we know that this is
a bit hard so can we do better in this
uh
in this setting
uh to tackle oops to
come up with an algorithm for for this
we will look at the multi-marginal
formulation of this problem which was
also introduced by again
in the
paper original paper
which is a uh pretty simple to
[Music]
prove and to define yes
so what is what is um
so you said something is npr so it's uh
it's about uh
it's not about something right it's
about computing the the the band
so there are several things that are so
i'm not an expert in this uh i don't
know if somebody you can know better
about this but i care the the npr ness
is to compute the actual value of the
variance
itself is already hard
in the dimension the
number of points each uh and the input
like the the distributions that you want
to average
uh they are given by uh directs like
that or they are
they are supported by they are not
continuous
i mean
yeah they are finally supported
all right thanks
this
this value that is actually np how to
compute and also the mu star
this multi-marginal formulation gives
another
point of view on this problem
and it's saying that so this is if i
recall this is like the the variance of
my problem the one that i'm trying to
minimize over all the mu
can be rewritten as
the average of the integral of some cost
function c that is just defined right
here
which is a variance of my underlying
points
integrated with respect to gamma and
gamma here
is a
coupling with n
marginal that i've fixed which are my n
measures from which i'm looking for the
the barycenter
and then once i have my gamma star that
is solving this problem here
i can push forward this gamma star i can
yeah so i can prefer this gamma star
with the average map that from x 1 x n
gives me the sum of the lambda x i and
this gives me the actual very sometimes
you start original
thing that we wanted to do here
is
well we have another formulation which
is simpler and we want to look at
gradient flow gradient descent versus
time gradient descent of this uh second
problem the multi-marginal one however
here we have a constraint on the
marginals
so to
make our life simpler we just added a
penalization on the modulus and we
arrive
to this formulation of the problem
which is
not exactly our
original one so we have an extra alpha
that will account for the penalization
so we remove the constraint on the
marginals and instead we say we're going
to minimize
this same uh
problem
with that constraint but instead we have
this penalization that is
that we chose to to take in the
chi-square divergence between gamma i
that are my marginals of gamma
and new i that are the marginals that i
want to have for my margin for
library center
okay so let's just uh start to compute
this
uh
so
i'm not gonna
uh remind how to uh compute the
versatile gradient uh in general i'm
just gonna
leave it here so my f alpha is what i
recall here
and i want to take the gradient the
gradient is i have a first term that is
just the gradient of this part so now
i'm looking so i'm looking at the gram
gradient with respect to gamma my my big
measures that belongs to this space
sorry sorry written here
so this is a function that goes from
rdn to rdm this first function
and then here i have the gradient of
future of my chi square and this is a
gradient of gamma i over i
except that here my gamma i are from rd
to rd and not from rdn toward n so what
i mean when i write this is actually
uh i have a big big
vector field that is valued in rdm where
i put 0 everywhere i is different from
j is different from i and here i put
this gradient
okay so at the end what i end up with is
uh my big gradient is alpha
lambda i
lambda 1 gradient of
gamma 1 over mu 1
equivalent of gamma
n over mu n
this is what i would like to uh to
implement
for doing a grading descent of my
function f alpha
so i cannot do that because i don't have
access to gamma i which is a
function where i'm at and to do that i
do a
a canada easy thing i do so to we will
end up with what is svg that has been
introduced by luan 1 in 2016
and
what they do is i replace
here this gradient
by
the same thing
convolved with a kernel
and with a
integration by part i can see that this
is equal to these two terms
why do i do this integration by parts is
because when i do this
i have here an integration respect to
gamma i
which are my marginals of my current
measure gamma
which can be approximated by the average
with my particles
so this is what what i do when i write
here you know if you start too small
it's a bit small but it's going to be
bigger on the next slide
so these two things are like
approximation of this integration with
respect to gamma i
so i have uh at least for now a
continuous time
algorithm that i can
implement approximately
and so this is
just the
the bassastein flow that i would like to
implement prior to the canalization and
once i analyze it and i
discretize it i have this uh
algorithm that is the whole thing that
is written here
it looks a bit uh oops okay
it looks a bit uh big but it's
just uh
discretizing what is above
and i have two terms
one that is an interaction between each
marginal each varginals that will bring
all my marginal clause together and make
all the
the
marginal trying to be on
all equals
which is what the transport is trying to
do is try to make all the marginalized
equal or close to each other and then
there is a second part that is in
interaction between
the same original but all the particles
that is going to try to put all
particles uh spread all the particles
that they resemble they are close to
what they're supposed to sample
and this is supposed to give me a good
approximation of my gamma star alpha
which is the minimizer of the f alpha
that i
am trying to minimize i'm just going to
show some uh already numerical
experiments
um
because regarding the algorithm is
pretty much what we have for now
um
so i'm going to start with the drawing
on the on the bottom so here i just have
a
dimension one
i just have
two uh marginals it's very the simplest
case we can find
and uh we have 50 particles oh i think
or less and we start on this drawing on
this
graph at the bottom we start with
the green points that are the starting
particles and we make them evolve
and with this
algorithm
and we see that they
go towards this golden line which is a
transpose optimal transport from the two
marginal
and
the the red red points are the ones we
have at the end
and if we look at the
each marginal
uh
and the barry center is what we have
there so the first marginal is a gray
line here
the second marginal
here is the other gray line oops sorry
and uh when we take the
average of these two uh module or the
average of these two particles we have
some distribution which is the blue one
over there and the black one is supposed
is that the true barycenter that was
supposed to be cluster
here is the same thing but with three
marginal so that's why we have this uh
3d uh
drawing a big at the bottom so we are
again in dimension one we have also i
think about 50 particles and we have the
same same thing that happened so it
seems to be working we have our green
points over there
that are the the one where we start
the
black line are the the how they move and
at some point they arrive
pretty close to this golden line which
is the supports of the gamma star that
we're trying to
approximate
okay so what we've done so far is uh
trying to understand if f alpha is a
good thing to consider and to minimize
namely if
we minimize fsf alpha and get our gamma
star alpha
and look at the barycenter associated to
this which is the forward again
with the average the underlying space
of my gamma alpha star
this mu alpha star which is my
approximate bicenter is close to the two
by sometimes you start
this might not be true in general
because in particular mustar might not
be unique so it doesn't even make sense
to ask this question however again kali
showed that if one of the new eyes
is absolutely continuous with respect to
le beg sorry
the bag measure
then mustard is unique and we can see
that in this uh problem it's not very
hard to see
that um
in this case mu star alpha is also
unique so we can talk about the
proximity
and the the the key ingredient or the
key uh
assumption that we make for this which
are actually what the but the important
part of the talk turkeys
is the following one uh which we call a
variance inequality which we can read
write again or rewrite
as an excel like
the
first part is a variance at mu the
second part is the variance at the
minimum
and so this inequality is also called a
quadratic growth inequality in
optimization
because we are
asking that around the minimum there is
a quadratic growth of my function f
and in particular if we suppose that
this happened for a positive k this
implies
that there is a unique barycenter
and at the exact
extreme point where k is equal to zero
then we end up with just asking that mu
star is the very center so for this
happening for a small k is something
that we hope could happen
easily or
very often as soon as
we have a unique new star
[Music]
and uh
from this uh
variant inequality that i will go back
to
in a minute
we were able to show
that the mu star alpha which is the
minimizer of my uh
f alpha for the very center associated
the minimizer my uh alpha is close
actually to uh my new star with a raid
that is of
one over alpha
so we had an extra assumption that the
marginals from which we want to take the
barycenter uh follow up satisfy a
principal inequality actually it's not
very necessary we just we have a slower
rate without this
but the important part being i think the
variance inequality
and so the variance inequality with
constant k this k arrived here
so when do
does this uh balance inequality hold so
to try to understand why where does this
advanced inequality come from like when
does this happen
i'm going to go back on my
drawing on spheres and see
try to get some intuition of what could
happen so i'm gonna look at the sphere
and i know there is one uh
typical
example where there is no unique uh
barycenter which is if i take one point
x1
and the north pole and one point uh x2
on the south pole every point on the
equator will be a barycenter so i know
that in this case i don't have
uniqueness but i will need uniqueness to
be able to
ensure that
i can approximate my
very center i need to have it properly
defined
so in this case i'm in the like the case
we have no uniqueness
what i can do is once i have this uh
these two points
i can my x1 here
x2 here you can choose the barycenter
that isn't the
equator and and call it x-star
and then i will draw the
the j-d6 that start from this x-star and
go to x1 and x2
and i pull my 2x1 and x2 closer to my
very center so i end up
with two points here
that we call x2 minus and x1 minus
because they become closer so i have a
distance in first and it becomes closer
to my x star and in this case it's uh i
start to have uniqueness it starts
becomes my unique uh minimizer and i'm
and i'm and i'm hoping that things are
more stable in this situation because
all points are closer to x-star and i'm
closer to the tangent space like
everything is closer to the tension
space that i didn't really
define here but
uh i mentioned before but hoping that
everything is closer to the tangent
space and closer to
the occlusion case where everything is
uh working well
and there is a
third example that i want to mention
is the opposite
where i still have
my two points x1 and x2
my
south and north pole
i choose the same x star
as the very center and this time
these geodesics that come here
i push my x1 and x2 on the other side of
the sphere
so i would have
on the other side on the sphere my x1
plus here and x2 plus here
and in this case since i reach the
non-unique test when i'm pushing further
x-star is not uh
it's not price center anymore
of my
new uh you know not presenter
of
x1 plus
x2 plus
from this drawing the hope we have is
that
once we have our two measures uh our
points around our very center if we're
able to
push them away from the barry center and
still having the same bary center we're
hoping to be in the in a case where
everything is behaving well and have
a variance inequality it's not a proof
but this is the intuition behind
why the following theorem
is true which is when i have x-star to
the very center of some points on the
um so uh yeah it's very center of
0.61xn with the respective wizard
weights
on a positive curve geodesic space just
like the sphere and opposite space if i
push them away
from x star by a factor one plus lambda
i end up with my x i plus that i defined
here and if x i plus
have the same barycenter x star
then i satisfy the variance inequality
with the
[Music]
constant lambda over one plus lambda
i guess now how does this translate for
the massachusetts space what does it
mean to be able to extend the
geodesic for the versatile space
so it's pretty uh easy to check
so my jedizik from
two points yeah sorry so i don't have
time to do it so i'm going to skip it
but it's pretty easy to check
uh that to be to extend that just asking
that the transport map is
the gradient of a function that is not
convex but
lambda over one plus lambda of x so i
ask strong convexity of my potentials
instead of just convexity for the
potential that emanates from
my measurement star toward the
new eyes
and there is a
result by uh
sino and the scene and the collaborators
uh taylor and philip
that shows that so if the music
so it's a corollary
to be exact of what they should if mu
star has a density respect to the bag
the absolutely continuous respect to the
back and the support of mustard is
a whole rd if all counterfeit potentials
are alpha
i strongly convex then you satisfy a k
variance inequality
that is the average of this
alpha i
okay and so the since i'm
going over time
the last uh style of some few numerical
experiments so the typical case where we
don't have uniqueness
is i take uh
one let's say i mean dimension two i
take one gaussian that is
supported on the one-dimensional
vertical space i take another question
that is supported on a one-dimensional
horizontal space
and what we did here as an experiment is
we
we um inflated a bit discussions so that
they have rds as a
as a whole space but they have
uh
uh for covariance matrices
epsilon one zero zero and the same thing
where one and epsilon inverted and we
see that uh so the
the
real barry center of this two measures
is supposed to be the
level the the one that uh
one with the level set there are black
here and instead we have this red dots
that our algorithm is giving us
and in this case we have an alpha that
is very small so in this case the
algorithm is not working very well
with a small alpha but as with as we
increase alpha we see that we're going
closer to what we're supposed to to
obtain and in particular in gray here
this is the marginals the marginal are
again getting closer to what they're
supposed to be which is the aggressions
um so we have a lot of
work to do
in particular
so i'm writing what rate of convergence
but
coverage itself is not proven either
we don't have uh the the function f
alpha is not just convex so we cannot
apply simply uh this
what would be the dependence on the
dimension is another thing that we would
like to understand
um i didn't mention why we chose svg to
uh compare to uh other um
potential ways to uh sample from the
module but there is one reason that i
can
i can talk about offline
um and the other thing is this is uh
related to um unbalanced uh problem
because the
scale divergence that we added
to to take to ramp to replace the
constraint allow us to have measures
that are not necessarily um
with the same mass
and so how does this uh
work in this case and also another
interesting question i know some people
are interested with other costs
uh but this uh parents inequality uh
i don't know what they mean with this
other course they don't have this
interpretation so this is another open
question
and
thank you for your attention
any questions
all right so why why
you said that
you have a justification
yeah so
the
we want to arrive so if you remember the
the
drawings that i did there was uh
the experiment that we had there was a
golden knife which is a transports where
we want all our points to arrive
and if we look at for example a
larva so if i have one particle and then
i apply a smaller
cushion to it then i know that all the
time i will jump out in a direction
outside of this but i want everything to
get fixed in this and another thing is
the direction in which
it will jump
will depend only on the ground log of
mui
and this information is not enough to
know what is the optimal transport
so a single particle doesn't have enough
information to know in which direction
it needs to go it needs to have
information from all the particles to
have
uh an idea of what the optimal transport
is to know in which direction it's
supposed to go
so we need something that is
deterministic or are just traveling
along the transport maps and we need
something that
knows about all the particles
to guess well to get to estimate this
transport map implicitly okay
again